واذ يستمر الاحتلال النازي في حربه
العدوانيه على شعبنا لليوم الال وال فقد
صعد في ارتكاب المجازر والجرائم بحق
المدنيين العزل والنازحين والمرضى والجرحى
والمستشفيات بدعم وغطاء وسلاح امريكي خلال
اليومين الماضيين حيث تكشف حجم المجازر
المروعه التي ارتكبها جيش
الاحتلال دا خ وفي محيط مستشفى الشهيد
كمال عدوان وجريمه قتله النازحين ودهس
وجرفه وهم احياء وارتقاء الشهداء من
النساء والاطفال كما ارتكب النازيون الجدد
مجزره مروعه اخرى في جباليا بحق المدنيين
العزل ومجزره بحق عائلتي البرش وعلوان
الكرام في جباليا البلد ارتقى خلال هذه
المجازر 100 وع من الشهداء بينهم 50 طفلا
وعشرات المفقودين واستهدف هذا الاحتلال
الفاشي بالقصف الهمجي ايضا مدخل مستشفى
الشفاء ومبنى الجراحه فيه الذي يضم الجرحى
والمرضى واغلبهم من الاطفال والنساء حيث
ارتقى
26 شهيدا من النازحين في المستشفى ولا
يزال هذا الاحتلال يقصف ويح صر ويدمر
المدارس التي تؤوي مئات الالاف من
النازحين في قطاع غزه شمالا وجنوبا مسقطا
كل كذبه الذي تحدث فيه عن اماكن امنه في
قطاع غزه لقد دمر هذا الاحتلال خلال 73
يوما كل المستش المستشفيات في قطاع غزه
دمر كل المستشفيات في قطاع غزه التي تعد
شريان الحياه النجاه لاكثر من مليوني
مواطن فلسطيني واخرجها عن الخدمه جميعا
ولم يكتفي بذلك بل واصل قصفها وحصارها
وتدمير بنيتها التحتيه واعتقال كوادرها
الطبيه والتحقيق معهم تحت التعذيب
والتجويع حيث لا يزال
38 كادرا طبيا بينهم الدكتور محمد ابو
سلميه مدير عام مجمع الشفاء الطبي في
امعان همجي وسادي في قتل شعبنا وتشريده
وتهجيره خلال 70 خلال 73 يوما من هذا
العدوان ارتقى قرابه 19000 من الشهداء
واكثر من
52000 جريحا من من النساء والاطفال ودمر
كل مقومات الحياه الانسانيه من مبان سكنيه
ومرافق خدميه ولا يزال هذا الاحتلال
النازي يعتقل المئات من ابناء شعبنا في
قطاع غزه بينهم النساء ويمارس بحقهم شتى
صنوف التعذيب الوحشي حيث ارتقى عدد منهم
شهداء ولا يزالوا الباقون رهن الاعتقال في
معسكرات قرب بئر السبع ومعسكر عنتوت قرب
القدس يريد